[Applause]  [Music]   [Applause] [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we all have a story to tell  but what makes each one different  [Music]  not how the story ends  but rather the place where it begins  [Music]  oh holy god  my mom says if we went across the water  they wouldn't understand the way we talk  if they can't understand you then  they're not listening  you know who you are would you  your buddy from belfast where everybody  knows you  hey buddy  [Music]  we're looking to cleanse the community  away but you wouldn't want to be the old  man out in the street  talk to my family and i'll kill you  are we gonna have to leave belfast we'll  fight this together  this is that this is what  this is war  we're living in a civil war  what do you want  i want my family with me  i want you  [Music]  are getting killed we can give these  boys a better job than we ever had  [Music]  go now  don't look back  [Music]  you